[Music]
it seems machine learning is everywhere
nowadays and missed so many offerings
for you as a mobile developer it can get
really confusing as to where you should
start I'm Miriam Ulukaya an engineer on
the firebase team and I'm here today to
introduce you to the options that are
available to you if he could carry data
centers in your pocket with unlimited
battery it will be much easier but using
your mouth for mobile apps means
thinking about the processing power
battery consumption and connectivity of
our device there are a number of factors
that will dictate the amount energy and
tools you'll want to use like whether
you want to keep the data local if you
require low latency or if you need
access to the processing power of the
cloud luckily Google offers a number of
EMA options for mobile developers that
can help you develop and deploy m/l
models for the environment that fits
your use case to help you pick which
email deployment option fits best I'll
walk you through a few key decision
points the first question you should ask
yourself is where you want to perform
email inferences in the cloud or on the
device you would use a cloud if you are
already using an existing cloud service
for model inferences or you run
inferences infrequently and want to
minimize impact on the device battery
life or need to support older less
performant devices or if you need high
accuracy models that require the compute
power of the cloud on the other hand
there are cases in which it might be
useful to do email inference on the
mobile device for example if you want to
keep data local to the device you need
low latency such as RAM processing
multiple frames in quick succession you
want inferences
to work even when the devices of line or
your users may be in an area of the
world where high-speed wireless
connectivity is non-existent or
unreliable so now that you understand
all the considerations let me present
the options available to you first is to
run inference in the cloud and there's a
world of tools and API as you can use
these include cloud vision for image
recognition and classification club
natural language API for text parsing
and analysis auto ml that allows you to
customize models that are served from
the cloud all are available via REST API
I won't go into them all here but you
can learn more it cloud.google.com slash
products /ai slash building that blocks
next is to run inference on device and
you have two main options you can either
use TF light directly or you can use a
milk it for firebase a mark is a mobile
sdk that brings Google's machine
learning experience to Android and iOS
apps in a powerful yet easy to use
package it comes with a set of
ready-to-use api's both for on device
and cloud base inference they support
common mobile use cases like image
labeling face detection text recognition
and parkour scanning to name a few you
simply pass in the data to their market
library and it will give you the
information you need whether you are new
to or experienced with machine learning
you can implement the functionality you
need all in a few lines of code and it
includes both Android and iOS libraries
while the own device api's process data
quickly and Millward even when there is
no need for connection the cloud pays
api's leverage the power of Google cloud
platforms machine learning technology to
give a higher level
of accuracy if you have a use case
that's different than offered models and
Malkiel also offers the ability to
deploy an experiment with your own
custom tensorflow light models to run on
device inference it works like this
after converting your model to the TF
light format you can host and serve it
to your users analogies for firebase can
then be used tossed and dynamically
served here flight models to your users
and it provides convenient API that how
do you use your custom TF light models
in your mobile apps with emojis for fire
ways you can reduce the initial install
size of your mobile app and only
download the model where needed
dynamically swap models on the fly
without having to republish your app to
the App Store target different user
segments with models tailored
specifically for them run ad experiments
with multiple models to find the best
performing one if you'd like you can
also use your TF light model or mobile
directly with TF light api's these offer
blazingly fast inference times
particularly on Android devices that
support the neural network api's and a
variety of ways to host and deploy your
model for mobile developers looking to
implement machine learning into their
apps
there are several directions to choose
depending on how much flexibility you
want or have specific you your use cases
recover some key factors that help you
decide like whether you do your
inference on the device or in the cloud
and whether you want to use the pre
trained models Google provides or train
and bring your custom model check out
our full session at next for a deep dive
analysis live experiments and the latest
ml offerings from Google
[Music]